hey everyone this is Steve valentov with
collider and we're at the collider
Sundance studio and we are I want to
give a huge thank you to our sponsor
Saratoga Springwater
because coming to Sundance is expensive
and I really appreciate them as a
sponsor and what they'll find the cast
and filmmaker will discover is the water
is actually pretty good delicious
by the way I'm
yeah it's not good
[Laughter]
um I really I really honestly I
appreciate you indulging me
um it really it you know uh to bring the
crew out and cover independent movies
you can't do it alone you know um and
one of the reasons I get to talk to you
guys is you know anyway you you get
where I was going so um I guess I want
to start with the first question I want
to do for the actors uh before we get
into the movie this is a separate thing
if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what do you
want them watching first and why
um that's
tough if
I
really it's that is so interesting there
there was a there was a a little show I
I did called happen Leonard and um it
was like an independent television show
um and uh Mike K Williams was in it and
Christina Hendrickson I was coming out
of a really intense thing a divorce and
um I felt like like we were talking I
had nothing to lose and so everything
just exploded out of me
um and that's what I'm always trying to
shoot for and so yeah I'd ask people to
see that one I guess
foreign
maybe this one
um I like the character it's a
great movie
I would that was an option I would
actually
um
yeah
sorry I'm losing my voice it takes me a
little minute to digest like I still
don't know I still every time like we
just watch this movie and it's hard like
whenever you your face shows up on
camera it looks like a weird like mirror
memory of some weird well shot like
version of your memory so I can't really
I don't feel subjective but I feel like
in a year or two I'm gonna think
Starling girl on I just love this story
and the experience was truly one of the
best most fruitful artistic experience
in my life
um I second that I would I would say
stalingo I'd like Jimmy I didn't know
that was an option
um but now I guess I have to say
stalingo
um but it yeah it was one of the best
but I want to say stalingo it was um
yeah one of the best experiences I've
ever had on a set and felt very fruitful
as Lewis said uh what about my divorce
role guys though wasn't that that was
pretty cool huh anyway moving on right
uh
I really want to start with a sincere
congratulations on the film I thought
you guys did such a great job and you
did such a great job with the material
um and I am curious I read that um you
were oh actually before we get started
most people here watching the interview
will not have seen the movie yet so do
you mind actually talking about what the
film is about
um yes so
um the film takes place in a Christian
fundamentalist community in rural
Kentucky and it's about a teenage girl
who
uh is struggling with her place in in
the in the world in the community and
um but you know plans on living the life
that is expected of her and then things
start to change she starts to question
things when she meets uh or when she
sees again her uh youth pastor who
returns from a a year abroad and
things get dramatic I I read in the
Press notes and I don't know if you want
to talk about it that you experience
something in your own life that was
similar to what's being depicted in the
film
um how much had you been thinking about
using that in essence you know what I
mean like your real life sort of
Crossing with art
um yeah I mean I thought about it the
whole time
um definitely during the writing process
I think that was the most emotional and
cathartic part of it and then
interestingly like once we were on set
and directing I it was weird I kind of
like was able to divorce myself from
that a little bit and just be like I'm
the director I'm focusing on like
executing the script and and I felt a
little bit removed from from my
experience
um and then yeah in editing it was very
emotional again
um but yeah I mean I think there's so
much of myself and all of the characters
in gem especially especially at that age
um a lot of what happened was inspired
by things that actually happened to me
in this relationship and so yeah pretty
cathartic for all four of you I'm
curious uh what was it about the
material and the script that said I I
need to do this I want to be a part of
this film
um
uh well it's really was uh it's a really
well written script really really well
written one of my my favorite scripts
I'd read in a long time
um and then
at the time it was just like Eliza and
Lewis that were attached
and I just wanted to work with them
really and you know and then I saw the
world short
and uh and that was really great I was
just really wanting to work with like
really just people that I really liked
and you know yeah
oh I'm looking for more at the same yeah
yeah no I just uh it was the script the
script uh blew me away and also when I
read that and then saw what she can do
on film with her I think I saw two
shorts um and I was just stunned I was
like I need to work with this person I
can't believe I'll get to be in her
first future
yeah
um yeah I think I I a different from you
guys for me was the script you know
it really kind of sunk in for me when I
met with Laurel and I got the sense of
how she worked and what her vision for
the project was and kind of knowing what
uh what kind of you know this is sort of
like a tonal gymnastics you know so it's
quite an undertaking and after I met her
it was very clear that um I didn't want
to miss miss the boat
um yeah I well I I work before doing
styling girl I worked on a film that was
being produced by Cara Durrett who was
producer on stalingo and um she
presented the script to me and um Cara
is an incredible producer and uh
anything that she would recommend I
would I would do and then I met Laurel
and was like oh obviously I have to do
this it and the script
if I can do a follow-up for you this is
a really you deliver such a great
performance and it's a challenging role
that when you're reading the script when
you finally realized or when you got
attached and you found out you're going
to do the role were you like oh wow this
is really going to challenge me as an
actor and I really you know what I mean
yeah for sure I've I mean I've done
Coming of Age films before but I think
what made this one particularly scary or
challenging for me was the I guess the
sexual nature of it because
it's not just a they're not just
they're very troubling
um like the sexual nature of it is quite
troubling it's not just about falling in
love it's not as it's not like a simple
coming-of-age story
um so I've I wanted I don't want to give
anything away so
um yeah it felt conflicted and morally
complex and that's what I found
quite frightening about it which made me
want to do it I definitely this is not
I'm when you must when you read the
script I'm sure the same that you it's a
role that is challenging and requires
um I'm just curious when you're getting
ready for a role like this and you're
playing the person in this side of a
relationship you know what how do you
prep for that and you know when you were
thinking about being on set you know
what I mean like in terms of getting
ready for this role and um if you could
talk a little bit about that yeah yeah
um I mean I really just tried to immerse
myself in the world and immerse myself
in all the material that Laurel was
feeding me which is
um was incredibly helpful
um you know I I drew from experiences
with some of my family friends who are
um pretty Christian out in Montana and
um that the the the the parts that I
like about Owen is what I was drawing
from them
um and then you know we had a week of
rehearsal beforehand that Laurel really
projected um in the schedule and that
was I think for me one of the most I was
really terrified but after that week of
rehearsal I felt like uh like maybe it
was a hill we could climb or I could at
least one of the one of the things about
the film is that it deals with Christian
fundamentalists but it doesn't
um portray them in anything less than
these are just who they are it's not
going after that you know that people
that are believe that um can you sort of
talk about why it was important you know
what I mean like making sure that you
give everyone a fair Shake totally yeah
I mean that was something that
um you know was important from the very
beginning I didn't want to tell a story
that was like condemning or mocking
these communities
um it was really about
trying to get into
these characters head spaces and and
help I wanted the audience to to feel
for them and and to see themselves in
the story you know the thing is is like
the oppression is there obviously but I
think it's kind of boring to just focus
on that part like we've seen those
movies and like there's lots of really
beautiful beautiful things about
close-knit communities and faith that I
wanted to portray in addition to
everything else
um so
yeah and I think
yeah it just makes for a more
interesting film truthfully like I it's
boring when you feel like you're just
like being like propaganda is being
pushed into your face of like feel this
way about these people like you want to
get invested in the story you want to be
you want to take the audience on a ride
and feel for these people rather than
just like standing back and and judging
I have to do another follow-up I
apologize to all the actors here
um I'm fascinated by the editing process
because that's where the film comes
together so I'm curious how did the film
change in the editing room in ways you
weren't expecting
um
I mean nothing I think terribly out of
the ordinary you know
some of my favorite scenes we ended up
cutting just for time
um I think
I think maybe what I what was unexpected
for me was how we incorporated score
um which there wasn't that much of
actually ultimately in the end like
music is a very important part of this
film and there is a lot of music but you
know there's so the film is a pretty
emotional film like
there's there's a lot of ups and downs
and I was very very conscious of
protecting I never wanted it to feel
overwrought I never wanted it to feel
melodramatic and because it could very
easily if you're in that direction
um and just so I noticed while when we
were editing like certain times where I
thought that we were going to have
musical cues it was like I don't need it
man like it's gonna feel really
manipulative and overwrought with that
like I just want to be with these actors
and like and experience the tension and
the silence and
um and I'm so glad and you know a big
part of this film what we're trying to
do is
we want the audience to be with gem the
entire time we're in her perspective the
entire time and
um I didn't want to like put too much
on to her experience like through music
or editing like I wanted the audience to
experience it without manipulation as
much as possible if that makes sense and
make them lead them to make their own
dis decisions about what's going on or
feelings about it rather
um again it relates back to like I don't
I don't like watching movies where like
things are being pushed in my face I
want to be challenged I want to like be
like rooting for something and then be
like oh wait why did I want that and
um
that's just to me those are my favorite
kinds of movies to watch so I wish we
could put up right now a well maybe an
editing but like an example of like a
scene where it's like the music is just
so overdone to make you feel a certain
way for sure you know a moment in this
film where there is no music and the all
you know exactly what you're talking
about yeah I mean it's you know you
could you do it all the time in editing
we're constantly putting temp stuff in
trying it out and and there were places
where I didn't think we needed music and
then we put it in I was like oh it's
actually really great
um but yeah certain scenes are just so
much more powerful without it uh for the
actors I'm curious obviously this was
not a Marvel movie and there's a finite
time and schedule and I'm just curious
what day on the shoot what day on the of
the shooting schedule maybe did you have
circled as oh this is going to be a day
oh
every day
was there though a day on the schedule
that you really had as a this is really
going to be you know I'm a little
nervous or I'm a little scared or I'm
going to have to be emotionally drained
by the end
it really does feel like all of your
scenes are those kind of like hot
pockets of the schedule but what about
there's a scene that was cut that was
really scary to do
that was my take we can't talk about it
what about what about your first day
Lewis oh well I didn't have time to get
scared because it was just sprung on me
what about what about
shooting in the water at night
that was that was a day yeah
[Music]
it was cold we were sitting in a lake at
what time early hours it was like 3 A.M
and it had been really hot every other
day except this day and we were like
all right
you can't tell though they were so
worried that you would be able to see
like them like shaking during the
performance but you can't tell
also we had an hour to shoot that scene
it was a nightmare but it's one of my
favorite scenes I love that scene yeah I
love that one too well there's a you
know oh I feel like on Independent
movies there's always like
it's you're like really always pressed
for time but for me on this at least I
felt like Laurel and then also like Kara
or so
um I feel like calm and like steering
the ship and not like frantic
um that it uh
it they just did a really good job of of
keeping calm even though maybe we didn't
have that much time and it didn't feel
like pressed or pressured you know
um so I felt like everyone could like
relax and do their job uh do their job
better you know so that's really cool
that they
have like that you know Karen Laurel
together they steered that ship so
serenely we had no idea if they were
ever stressed out it was crazy it was
crazy that's the idea yeah I want you to
know well played I'm curious for the
actors
um uh because I don't want to do
spoilers around this so I'm just going
to act an acting question if you will
um when you know that you have a very
emotional or dramatic scene or scene
you're really nervous about say it's
happening on a Monday how early on are
you mentally preparing for that scene is
it when you first have the script it's
like soda in your subconscious during
the shoot like how do you get ready when
you know you're gonna really have to
deliver something on a certain day
we don't really have the luxury of like
having
a process that will be tended to by each
production so it for me it varies
differently ideally it would start from
the beginning and then you have time to
slowly unpack it
but you know it just whatever the
project requires is often what you have
to come up with
I also
find that with smaller films When
there's less time and you're
you know you have to pack in so many
scenes in one day there's this intensity
to the shoot that sometimes makes you
more vulnerable on the day and
um you know some people like to do the
work and other people don't just really
depends but I I find that when you're in
that environment you just feel
you have to feel so vulnerable all the
time that those emotions
are more easily accessible
but it's it's but also some days you
just
as much as you prepare it just doesn't
happen for you and that's
that's the hard part about acting I
think you're very good at it I have to
say just trust no you I mean
you know you will see you will see
oh there's two more people who need to
respond please
[Music]
um
yeah well uh I feel like uh
for me I I I don't like I don't know you
know I just kind of don't know what's
gonna like come out or come up you know
so many times I'm like when it is the
emotional stuff I'm just kind of
surprised by it you kind of have to like
for me
it's kind of just like letting it go and
just feeling whatever happens
um because when you're trying to like
search I mean just not even in that
those situations but in any situation
like when you're trying to search for an
emotion then it becomes like an idea and
you aren't feeling an emotion
and so
for me it's it's I mean I guess maybe
there's some unconscious thing where
you're steering yourself in that
direction and not to say that you
definitely don't like think about it or
think about that scene or whatever it is
but
um I think there's kind of just a part
of I I just don't know really what's
going to happen you know and you just
kind of have to let go
um at least for me that's what I've
found has
been what's been going on
yeah that's what's cool about it and
also uh can be like frightening about it
just because you don't know what's going
to happen you know
um I would say it depends on the scene
it depends on the
you know what's what what the emotion is
but I've found there's a delicate
balance between
um you know Conjuring up a lot of the
debris
um at the right time if you do it too
soon then you're gonna bleed out like a
balloon and every time you by the time
you get to the shooting day you're going
to be a little empty so I don't know I'm
still trying to find that sweet spot
it's interesting because I've spoken to
a lot of people and they say that when
you are in uh say you have to someone
you know died and you need to portray
that scene on camera there is no right
way to do it it's whatever a character
might like it's it's just you know
there's no right there's no exact
science for acting and no matter you
know what I mean
honestly with what's so amazing about
working with actors and what's work
working with all of these actors who are
incredibly talented is they all have
pretty different processes which is but
that's so great and that's really fun
for me and it's fun to figure out you
know what works for each one of them and
um and especially like you know the week
of rehearsals that we got to have was so
beneficial for you know to figure out
what makes you guys tick
um what will work on the day and we
really I think in our rehearsal we got
to play I try to like as best I can
create an environment where we can just
play and mess around and like who gives
a whatever we come up with like
we'll try that oh it sucks who cares
whatever just so that like just I think
that for me anyway that that feeling of
play inspires me the most that feeling
like there's no wrong answer right now
and there are wrong answers I think here
and there but but you know we figure it
out and then on the day like we have a
set of tools we have a set of like
intentions that we know we can try out
and pull up from that worked well for us
so fun
I have to wrap with you guys but before
I do I have individual questions for
everyone but they're never going to let
me do it so I'm just going to ask two of
you an individual question I apologize
to everyone else but um Jimmy I'm going
to start with you I'm sorry uh I am so
curious about this show dark matter
because I'm fascinated by the Multiverse
and um what can you tell people about it
well it's it's just to show an apple but
let's talk more about this let's talk
more about this movie I the problem is
that um I've already been given the
wrap-up signal so I'm trying to sneak in
okay oh thank you you know what I mean
it's good it's kind yes who else do you
have okay I'm going to look down there
um oh yeah we are so curious about
Salem's Lot and Steve me too man
I don't know anything I don't know when
it's coming out
I wish I knew morning Brothers it's it's
in limbo or something
um but I'm excited hopefully people like
it but this is definitely going to come
out before that does
listen my job on as a reporter is to ask
about some other things once in a while
for sure I appreciate it I appreciate it
yeah you know like you know but listen
um I really mean it when I say
congratulations on being part of
Sundance with this film and I'm so
thankful you guys came in and I'm happy
to help you promote it thank you so much
thank you these are great questions man